Stormy Daniels do I call you stormy yes
I'm happy for that for an interview
absolutely it's Miss Daniels if you're
nasty
you've I mean you're probably right now
the most famous woman on planet Earth
how does that how does that feel
terrifying does it yeah and surreal it
just doesn't make sense
everyone thinks they know you very few
people I guess know you properly
what has it been like for you to go
through this extraordinary political
Maelstrom
um God there's like so many facets to
that answer I mean it was completely
shocking at first you know I was pretty
established I had my fan base I was well
known in the adult industry I mean I've
been a contract star for a long time you
know both as a performer writer director
all of that stuff and I had really
solidified my place and where I wanted
to be there so there was this like
instant explosion
but my fan base switched like the people
that had been my followers my fans for
the longest time were a completely
separate demographic than the ones I was
totally being
you know swarmed with you know I was
dancing in strip clubs which I had
always done but used to be I go on stage
and most of the people would be you know
white guys in suits very much like you
and then suddenly overnight I walked out
on stage and all of those guys were gone
and it's
gay men and trans people and women a lot
of women really just this whole other
crowd and dynamic so that was you know I
guess Shell Shocked would be the thing
and um and then just the misconceptions
and the shock that came with that you
know I had been in porn for a long time
I had a thick skin I wasn't surprised by
being called like you know [__] sled or
you know all of that stuff but it was
the
being treated inhuman like next level
which was really really shocking and
then that narrative started to change
and people started to call me like
really crazy things like a hero and like
this Champion for the me two minutes so
then I started to feel like I was being
pulled in all of these different
directions where people
sometimes on purpose sometimes
inadvertently we're trying to use me to
fit their cause and their narrative and
what they wanted to get out of it you
know and that was never the case I was
just telling the truth what I've been
struck by is a lot of women I know
actually quite high profile women it has
they find you very admirable they think
that you've actually grown to represent
female empowerment the way you stood up
to power the way you've refused to back
down the way you fought your corner and
the way you've defended your industry
where many people have as you say tried
to sort of dehumanize you and shame you
for and you've had none of that right
has that been nice for you to see a lot
of women actually come around and now be
on your side oh yeah absolutely
especially you know people who work in
the adult industry you know it was a big
deal for me there was all these
misconceptions that people in our
industry either work in that business
because they can't do anything else
because they're too stupid to do
anything else or they're broken or
they're you know failed at mainstream
actresses or whatever I'll tell you
right now that some of the smartest
women I've met have been in the adult
industry you know
um so that's really cool to sort of see
us taken a little more seriously
um and uh you can't really shame
somebody who's
been seen naked everywhere like what are
you gonna do release nudes of me
please do good for business right
so Donald Trump yesterday became the
first former president of the United
States to ever be arrested to sit in a
courtroom facing criminal charges did
you watch it
um a little bit yeah it was on I mean it
was on every channel so I try not to pay
too much attention because it just
starts to like the gravity of the
situation and it has nothing to do with
Trump and it has nothing to do with
stormy but like when you look at it as a
whole like this is really happening in
our country and no matter if it goes in
his favor or you know my favorite
Democratic Republic it's it's gonna just
be more divisive and it's you know at
first I thought I'd be really excited
you know I thought that when that day
came because I didn't think it would and
then I really didn't think it would you
know
um I thought he was going to get away
with not being held accountable so when
I found out that it was coming or
potentially coming I thought that I
would feel excited and Vindicated
but it was kind of anti-climactic was it
how interesting yeah when you saw him in
the court what did you feel
um
part of me was you know finally like he
had to go in and be under the rule of
someone else he had to obey the the
judge and walk through like a you know
the King has been dethroned he's no
longer Untouchable
um and nobody should be Untouchable it
doesn't matter if what your job
description is whether you're the
president like
um you should be held responsible for
your actions but the other side of it
was like this is someone that our
country elected and chose was there no
better option right you know I mean like
this is just
honestly if I there's a range of
emotions but I think sad was the one
that was
the most impactful and shocking for me
how weird is it you'll still me Daniels
and you had a perfectly nice life really
until recently with all this sort of
mayhem
and suddenly there's this moment in
American history and it's happening in a
courtroom and it's only really happening
because of you I mean if you chart back
the Genesis of this court case if he
hadn't through his lawyer which is what
the allegation is paid this money to you
he wouldn't be sitting there right and
that's a lot you know
um a lot of the nasty messages and stuff
I get really feel like it's my fault
that you know that I've made America the
laughingstock or I'm the fall of
democracy I wish I had that much power
but your only crime it seems to me is
that you call the truth well you got
paid 130 000 and someone's got to
explain why you got paid that I mean
right which I didn't even realize the
gravity of the situation at the time or
you know the repercussions of that but
you know I'm not responsible for all of
us
bad behavior or the charges against them
by any stretch I mean I'm sure there's
this more than we can even imagine I
think he even goes on trial in a couple
weeks for rape it's not my I didn't I'm
not the fire I was the spark that Lit
the fuse that blew up the keg do you
think that this is the right fuse to
light putting aside your own feelings
about it almost happened to you there is
an argument that I've seen this actually
from media across the Divide really
liberal meter as well so I don't think
there's enough there to justify putting
a former president through this process
do you think I mean you've touched on
this but do you think it's healthy for
America and democracy
to go after Donald Trump over this
particular thing or would it have been
better to wait for what some would argue
or the more serious things January 6th
the Georgia phone calls uh the
possession of potential classified
documents and so on so I haven't to be
completely honest I haven't read the
indictment or I have no legal knowledge
of it
um but I agree with you to me those are
such more significant crimes you know
what I mean my thing is one person and
obviously it's the most important thing
to me because I am me and it's selfish
you know myself is
opinion but those
I mean the January 6th look how many
people got injured or you know what I'm
saying like it just seems like
that's a bigger thing but if this is
what leads to it I can't help but wonder
if
there's something we don't know right
well they haven't there is a belief they
may not have put everything into them
yeah what was already in a public domain
so we're gonna have to wait and see
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury but you may be asked to
testify if this ends up as a trial how
do you feel about potentially testifying
and a child will be watched around the
world
um I mean anytime you're
up in the public eye it's scary I mean I
used to get scared giving an oral book
reported school so I mean it's daunting
but I look forward to it you know what I
mean because
I have nothing to hide I'm the only one
that has been telling the truth and
you know I can't shame me any of them
more so
I feel like if they don't
it Paints the picture that they know
something about me that makes me
you know untrustworthy or not reliable
um so you want to have I do I do I think
having them call me in and put me on the
stand
legitimizes my story and who I am and if
they don't it almost feels like they're
hiding me and people will automatically
assume I would that oh that she must not
be a good witness she's not credible
like so there's no doubt if they ask you
to testify you will testify oh
absolutely
you told the Times newspaper in London
last week I've seen him naked there's no
way he could be scarier with his clothes
on valid
it was a funny line
and true I stand by it
do you want to see him jailed I mean not
necessarily for this particular
indictment but just generally would it
give you any kind of closure with your
time involving Donald Trump to see him
in jail
specific to my case I don't think that
his crimes against me are
worthy of incarceration I feel like the
other things that he has done if he is
found guilty absolutely because
a bigger problem is that if these
allegations against him or whatever else
that we don't know yet he is found
guilty or the evidence suggest that he
is or whatever and he doesn't
that it's going to just basically I mean
it opens the door for other people to
to think they can get away with doing
that and worse one of the problems with
this particularly actually the
indictments involving you and Karen
McDougall who's the other woman who
received a payoff
become very politically toxic because
Republicans and I understand this they
say look it's different rules for Donald
Trump to what it's been for Democrat
politicians and they say John F Kennedy
John Edwards Bill Clinton all had
similar scandals some far worse none got
indicted that there seems to be a
political bias there
that's one way of looking at it another
way of looking at it because if you want
to look at the positive in this is that
we have made progress you know in our
justice system in our country and and
for women you know what I mean like if
that those other presidents had done
today what happened then would it be
treated the same or is it specifically
just people screaming this is a vendetta
against Trump but let's for a moment
here pretend that it was another
president or Clinton today and this
happened I mean look how I think that's
right post post me too exactly I think
there probably would have been actually
a different attitude to a lot of these
former Democrat politicians that's what
I hope and believe you know what I mean
like people just trashed Miss Lewinsky
and and you know all the way back
through history and
I would like to believe that those
things happen now that
it would be different of course he's
going to spin it and the Republicans and
the Maga people are going to spin it and
say like it's just because it's him but
is it really you know what I mean like
I'm hoping that it's just us moving
forward and you could apply that to you
know the way that's
you know racial crimes or handles or you
know what I'm saying like I just think
that it's hopefully a sign of progress
and I see everybody whoever you are have
a powerful you should be held
accountable oh absolutely but in this
case it's a sex scandal it's a woman
speaking out against somebody in power
and they want to say it's just because
it's him but I would like to believe it
doesn't matter that it's him he just
happens to be the one now you were a
registered Republican you still are so
for the Republican that's my favorite
you just made a whole bunch of people
watching this pee their pants right
because that just blows their whole
thing out there I mean a lot of them
probably don't realize I know you could
it's an easy thing to have you voted
Republicans I have not in the last
election
did you vote I didn't vote did you vote
for Trump in 2016. no you didn't you
never voted for him no I did not but you
have voted Republican before
and you never voted Democrat
no I actually didn't I mean that was so
long ago that I didn't vote which is a
terrible thing to say but you know we
should love it but I do think people
they'll be surprised I know
I know and the whole reason that I
registered and got him I feel like I
feel like the movie they just keep
dragging me back in you know like I have
no political aspirations not interested
try not to be interested and it just
keeps happening you know like that's how
the whole bigger registered Republican
came about was because of the draft
stormy campaign in 2009 which I didn't
even know about and the only reason I
got involved is because I was mad at the
guy for using my name and pictures
without my permission
and I think you had a brilliant releases
when you ran against that and for the
Senate and you had a brilliant slogan
which was screwing people honestly also
true I mean I love that because that was
extremely pertinent to what we're now
talking about obviously
um the Republicans who have a problem
with you say that what you're doing is
deliberately trying to derail Donald
Trump's 2024 presidential campaign he
doesn't need my help for that
laughs he's going to do that on his own
but does that even cross your mind I
mean do you think you should be allowed
to run again
um it is a free country and what I'm
surprised at is that the laws allow him
to um as it stands now I was equally
surprised I was like oh surely someone
who's indicted and whatever would be
exempt from being able to run
shocker to me last week that that
there's no rule against it well he could
actually be convicted and go to prison
right and still be president of the
United States that's the most absurd
thing to me that place my mind actually
me too I was like wait what
um and that has nothing to do with him
he could just be dude hey and do you
know what I mean like that just seems
like
beyond my comprehension but I guess they
never thought they would have to
make that role
Jenna Jameson a fellow adult
entertainment star said recently about
you the left looks at a as a whole and
just uses her to try to discredit the
president the right looks at a like a
treacherous rat it's a lose-lose should
have kept a mouth shot a trap shot what
do you what do you say to that
um part of that statement I think there
are people that
agree with that statement you know they
like I told you earlier people took my
story which is my personal thing and
just me speaking out and protecting
myself and standing up to bullies and
you know defending
myself against these personal attacks
um to try to fit it into their own
narrative whether it was you know
um the Republicans saying that the
Democrats sick they sent me there the
Republicans trying to say I was their
Champion I mean the Democrats trying to
say I was their Champion or the me too
movement or you know everybody tried to
use my story to fit their own we're all
trying to use you exactly and um
so part of that is true and I hate to
agree with anything that Jenna says but
part of that is true
um I am horrified and extremely
disappointed that this woman who came
from my industry from the same company
that I was with for 17 years and says
just keep your traps shut
she should be ashamed she has a daughter
I just that's
you know
do you think she means it in the sense
of you can't win so why even try I don't
know how I'm not going to presume to
know what what she
meant by it but
none of it's good
Donald Trump pled not guilty to all the
charges he's always denied having sex
with you
but he's never explained why if that's
the case you ended up being paid 130 000
by his lawyer right there's a
an inconsistency best about that
position at best yeah I mean he's full
of interests he's like I mean I
or somebody I should ask him that
question you know what I mean like but
it seems pretty obvious you know what I
mean like you have these people that
want to say that I was a prostitute and
paid that night so then I had this whole
other subsect I don't even know if you
know about this of sex workers and
escorts pissed at me for ruining
business really yeah for you know it's
like a doctor lawyer like client
privilege thing and I was like if that
had been the case I wouldn't have said
anything and if I was just trying to get
attention
I've had sex with some way hotter people
that are famous I would have told one of
those stories you know what I mean like
it wasn't a kiss and tell as a matter of
fact I took the money because I didn't
want anybody to know
um but there is that thing like if if
there was a transaction that was a raged
and that's what I went there for then
why was I paid over a decade later and
there's a couple things that as I've
been mulling this over
um
pretty obsessively in the last two weeks
like because it doesn't matter how many
times you put a fact out and you try to
tell people
that they just
you know what I mean like if you want to
call me a name
fine that's your opinion if you think
I'm fat or whatever and I'm not going to
try to change your opinion about porn
whether you don't agree with it for
ethical more well I'm not here to do
that I'm also not here to like change
your political opinions your stances on
something
but when you show a piece of evidence
that's
irrefutable and it's still just
you know I mean like hey I was met Trump
and the golf course at the you know that
event in Tahoe in 2006.
I wasn't paid until a decade over a
decade later so how is that being paid
for sex
I mean yeah I mean that's ridiculous it
is ridiculous I'm going to come to the
to the meeting I actually have a
personal
involvement in one part of it which you
probably don't even know about oh really
I'll just hold that over until we get
there but it's quite interesting I have
so many questions well it was
interesting to me when I read it
[Laughter]
where were you when you heard he'd been
indicted it was last Thursday my book it
was my birthday actually and I was I was
having a nice day and suddenly boom
this is
this is great so he had put out that he
was gonna be whatever and I even was
like he wouldn't know the day like he's
just he's up to something he always has
a plan so I didn't buy that one but my
attorney had said hey they want to talk
to you which we did you know
um I think it was like on a Thursday or
Friday this is the DA's office you're
right and he's a you know my attorney
called me goes hey if you need to get on
a plane tomorrow and come and testify
can you do it I was like oh my gosh I'm
gonna have to scramble I have you know
things I need to take care of and make
sure my you know my child has child care
all this all the details that have to be
done and then I got a call not very long
later said no no it's not going to
happen so it kind of was a little
disappointing and then it was all quiet
it's like oh my gosh he actually is
going to get away with this again you
know what I mean and uh
so I kind of forgot about it
and I had my phones on me all day you
know perusing no unusually quiet almost
and then I had put my phones down and I
went outside I was riding my horse and I
could hear it going off and your horse
is called Redemption Redemption is his
name I didn't make this off I can't make
this up the whole school Redemption
right I'm straddling a horse named
Redemption when he got indicted so when
I get off and my phone starts like
melting I was like what you know my
husband comes running out he was like
what just happened
one of the missed calls I had was for my
attorney so obviously that was the first
one I I made and what did you feel in
that moment I mean what was your honest
feeling because it's interesting I saw
that your your lawyer uh tweeted about
it and you had an interesting sort of
double reaction I would say right
because you said Thank you to a tweet
from your attorney Clark Brewster who
said Trump's indictment was no cause for
joy and the hard work and
conscientiousness of the grand jurors
must be respected now that truth and
Justice Prevail right so that was you
were thanking so yes I I agree with that
then you tweeted later that day thanks
for all the support to everyone and your
love I have so many messages coming in I
can't respond also don't want to spill
my champagne big smiley face hashtag
teamstormy merch autograph orders
pouring in too thank you for that
um
but it seemed to me that you and you've
alluded to this earlier that you had
kind of mixed emotions right so
hopefully you were well you tell me how
how you what were your emotions when you
heard about it so I I like I said I I
got off I'm scrolling oh my God my horse
is still standing here like you know
what's going on so I was like oh my gosh
I have to finish taking care of you know
my animal and go inside and in the
meantime Clark had written that
tweet that message which was you know
very wonderful you know I was so caught
off guard he's like so I just retweeted
it and in the moment I believe you said
you know there's no cause of joy in that
moment
I was you know just ecstatic plus I've
got all these messages coming in oh my
God congrats to you know just you're on
that high for a minute and then
um
and that's where you know
I was like no calls for Joy this is what
I've been fighting for like you know
like it's moving forward finally there's
lighted in it so I was very excited and
happy because ultimately I mean and I
actually wasn't drinking champagne I'm
I'm not allowed to drink champagne I get
I get white girl wasted it's not good
it's not a good look
but just to be clear the reason you
would feel so ecstatic is because it it
will possibly lead if this goes to trial
to you being Vindicated about telling
the truth exactly so of course he's
repeatedly called you a liar a lot of
people believe you've lied and this
would be the Vindication for you right
and that's really what's driving exactly
and so anybody would feel excited in
that moment but then hours went by and I
sat with it and started you know
reading and then I was like oh my gosh
bigger picture here is that
Clark was right there is no joy in the
fact that we had somebody in office that
had this much power to cause these you
know
Division and and
it he was right
but in the moment
you very quickly began getting threats
and you've had these before ever since
this first right became you know to the
public Consciousness but you got nasty
threats I mean your husband Barrett told
Vogue magazine there were threats are
going to kill you you're going to kill
your family you're going to set fire to
your house I mean horrific things
what impact did that have on you so
I'm used to getting
horrible messages every day
um even before this just being an adult
store I mean you're gonna get
um I will tell you that the first time
around back in 18
same thing like instant just flood it
and and how are you getting this on
social media or everywhere like
everywhere phone calls texts emails
people are calling you yeah so the first
time around it was mostly just liar you
know
um
gold you know gold digger you sold the
story which you just made the story up
because he's president which now we've
proven that like everybody knew about
this from before anyway that was the
tone you know what I mean and I would
say out of
realistically probably one in a hundred
messages was included some sort of a
death threat you know what I mean
and they would always be from like an
account that somebody created just to do
that no followers hidden you know that
kind of thing now
it's different
it's
the tone is different I would say it's
one in ten now and intent a death threat
yeah and they are way more specific and
graphic and just instead of just some
battling person like you're gonna burn
in hell I uh that kind of thing
more
serious I guess in a way
and they're not hiding it used to be if
you were they were going to do something
they would do it from a blocked number
or from a fake Twitter account these
people are using their actual phone
numbers and their actual emails and
their actual Twitter accounts which then
makes it worse because they actually
have followers right and the first time
around he was already in office
you know what I mean like I there's
nothing I could really do to to hurt him
he was President of the United States
right what am I going to do he'd already
made gotten the nomination all that
stuff so this time around they think
that it could actually hurt him this
time around he got indicted he could not
become president you know a lot of
people were you could stop him getting
back to the world right and whereas
partially be responsible for him you
know go to jail going to jail so there
are a lot more
passionate I guess that's a good word
enthusiastic uh with their threats and
they're not hiding and they sometimes
they genuinely feel
that they are doing something right that
they are the Patriots you know I told my
husband the best way to describe it is
before it was just like these rat like
loud mouth armchair anti-porn like
judgmental critical
people you know faceless now they are
doing it
like like a suicide bomber they truly in
their debts but more importantly in the
depths of their soul they feel like they
are doing the right thing does that make
sense Barrett said storm is tough she's
pretty good at laughing things off but
it does get to her of course and it's
clear from the way you're talking about
this that the scale of what's come your
way in the last 10 days or so it's just
been horrific
and then I guess they said that like the
um
it's not even until next December I'm
like oh my gosh There Goes My Summer
right I won't be able to go anywhere but
he must have a massive impact on your
life on the way you conduct yourself
where you go of course you know I spent
the first you know the first go-around I
didn't even pee by myself for almost two
years you know and I'm pretty
independent I'm pretty tough I'm just
I'm a you know writer and director and I
showed horses and and did my own thing
you know I don't and then suddenly I
didn't get to use the bathroom without
two big arm bodyguards watching me pee
for two years that's
that's a lot to have to go from somebody
who's so independent to basically having
an armed babysitter at all times and
then you just you learned all these
things like
make sure when you go every single place
you go into you know where the exits are
um placements in restaurants where I sit
in the car like just like I never my
bodyguards taught me and I don't even
know the reason for this honestly never
sit behind the driver you always sit
like all these little things that what
it what effect does that have on you and
your personality
um well I feel very
constricted you know what I mean like
repressed I'm also I can't do the things
I want to do or if you feel permanently
agitated nervous of course and you know
you're it makes you become paranoid and
anything you do or say it can be spun I
have a great story about that
um and one of my things I hate about the
Press I did a sore signing a book
signing at the sex museum in New York
for my book and there was a I don't know
the reporter's name he was there he was
there for hours he met my team he knew
what I'm signing I have a line of guys
my assistant Duane is next to me he's
handing me a book signing at one point
and we're almost done and I signed and
he makes a joke he said something funny
to me and I kicked out like that and
that the the Press guy got a photo of it
and that Stormy Daniels kicks man at
store signing
we were wearing matching jackets he was
my assistant like he wasn't some random
thing so then like you live in this
constant state of paranoia like what
could be twist change what can be
photography
clickbait I'm going to come to when you
first met Donald Trump but do you wish
you'd never met him of course
if I mean people say if you could go
back in time would you do it over
I say how far back does this time
machine go if I went back to 2016-18 or
whatever would I change what I did
sometimes In the Heat of the Moment I'm
like I wish I'd never yes but no I would
do it the same because I mean I've been
taking it back to 2000 it was the right
thing to do if I could go all the way
back to 2006. no if we could play
sliding doors yeah no can you meet him
get on the golf cart end up in his room
or you don't meet him oh I absolutely
would not have
absolutely you know I was I was
told I was invited to dinner let me go
through it so 2006 you're 27. he was 60.
you were the biggest porn star in the
world you just appeared in Judd Apatow's
40 year old virgin he said you were a
smart businesswoman he said you should
never be underestimated I mean he was
full of compliments Jonathan for you we
got Hollywood courting you for movies he
was the biggest TV star businessman in
the world and you meet were you a fan
before you met him
um to be honest I didn't have like a
hard opinion one way or another
I didn't watch his shows you know
obviously definitely knew who he was he
knew his face just gonna do you like the
sound of him or not or was he because
obviously he's very Brash he's very
arrogant yeah I mean I wasn't a fan and
I wasn't not a fan right you know you're
open-minded yeah and I was aware
of course you know I I wasn't like oh my
God I can't yeah no and I also was like
I hate that guy it was just like oh this
is
he's figured out how to do some stuff he
must be
good at what he does he's an interesting
guy regardless of whatever you think oh
yeah absolutely absolutely you meet at
this Golf Tournament in Lake Tahoe in
California you've been hired to host a
gifting sweet stand oh no it gets better
than that
tell me you don't appreciate the irony
and hilarity of a adult film company
sponsoring a hole
on a golf course
I mean
I do appreciate that my whole life is a
freaking Ethan outfit I could get
outrageous stuff right
so you were there to be one of the
hostesses for this gifting sweet stand
but also the Greek competitors between
the teas and you ended up in a golf cart
with Donald Trump what are you talking
about you two honestly on that initial
thing I didn't get a word in it was me
and the owner of the company and two
other girls and you know it was a brief
introduction I do remember his
hesitation when he's like this is you
know my contract girl this this is my
contract girl this is my contract girl
and director stormy and he was like oh
you also direct I was like yeah he goes
you know I was like look that's cool I
always like when they add director
um and so we we go on and another girl
there was definitely flirting with him
and Anna I wasn't interested
um I didn't even speak directly to him
other than a
nice to meet you and good luck year
round today or you know pleasantries
um it was at the gifting Suite later
and that's when he asked for your number
right was he pretty direct
um no he had his bodyguard to it Keisha
yes
oh I know well Keith's been with him but
I think
30 40 years maybe on and off I think he
I think he likes he likes Donald very
much but Keith was there yeah and you
get invited up to Donald Trump's Suite
which is at the top of the of the harah
resort and casino hotel but I wasn't
invited to his room I was invited to
have dinner to talk about a business
thing and this is oh this is one of
those other things that I didn't really
light bulb moment until this past week
why would you go to a hotel room of a
married man
oh my gosh
I get it and and justifiedly so people
when you say go to someone's hotel room
what do you think you think you open the
door and there's a bed and a dresser and
it's the size this is a huge penthouse
sweet yeah it was
it had a formal dining room we walked in
and there was a Fourier in a living room
and a dining room table and it's like an
apartment right I didn't even see the
bedroom at all for three hours not until
I went to use the restroom so it's not
like I went to a guy's hotel room and we
sat on the bed that would definitely be
more suspicious but you were not a naive
woman did you not assume that he might
have ulterior I did at the very
beginning so I was invited to dinner
um he said come up to the room and we'll
go down to one of the restaurants
whatever and I was a little bit early
and when I opened you know when I got
there he was in his pajamas and that's
when I was like oh hell no and I made
fun of him and he immediately changed
and was a perfect gentleman so you
actually said he would look like you
have yeah I made fun of him how did he
tell you that I asked him if you he
afternoon he stole his pajamas
knowing Donald Trump I suspect he didn't
find that very funny
uh
I was like I I I I was early and he said
he was running late and then he's like
excuse me I go put some clothes on and
and that's what he did and he came back
and was
there was no more red flags after that
you have dinner in the suite because
there is a dining room so no we actually
he's still owes me dinner ready I never
got my dinner or when I was there for
the meeting about I got nothing except
this what did you think you were there
for to have a meaning about a television
Chow about Celebrity Apprentice yes
so you had no dinner no no alcohol he
doesn't drink no do you drink a lot I
didn't at the time no
no so no alcohol no dinner no
you discussed the adult entertainment
business he's quite intrigued by the
business oh yeah and I think in
particular how many royalties you made
yeah off the films
um we had a
we had a pain to be to say this we had a
pretty good
conversation it was you know at first he
was arrogant we all I mean we beat the
story to death he was very arrogant he
was pompous he was puffed up I was
unamused and starving
and finally that's when I snapped and
was like somebody just spanking with
that magazine so it wasn't because he
kept showing you a magazine it was a
Money Magazine with him on the couch
right he just kept talking about how
these great things he was doing and all
this stuff and you eventually said I'm
gonna spank you so somebody should have
spank your things do you ever talk about
anything but yourself and he was who and
he walked it back and then there was
another at least
two and a half to three hours where we
talked and it was a did you like him I
did I was not attracted to him no no ew
no
I told you I was banging some hot
celebrities which ones were you I'm not
telling you that we can't just say I was
banging some hot celebrities not of
course take me to the water's edge and
not give me a drink still make out oh I
just did
[Laughter]
that's the art of the tease my friend
um book title don't you steal that
um but I mean we talked about he told me
you know about his golf course he was
having some problems some
environmentalists and and we talked
about something uh some condos or
something he was building it's been a
long time I don't remember he asked me
about the adult business and you know do
we have health care of royalty it's like
business questions and at no point did I
feel like he was checking out or
it was a good conversation he was like
what do you want to do and then I told
him and he was like now the more I think
about it the more I think about it my
idea is great and so we talked more
about so who had the first mention of
The Apprentice yeah he did oh he did
absolutely it was his idea that would
have never crossed because he'd done the
normal Apprentice for many years very
successfully and he was about to launch
Celebrity Apprentice right actually
based on a UK uh one-off episode for
charity which I took party
um and actually the series that he was
offering you in these conversations I
ended up taking part in that series and
I won it you took my part that was a
little bombshell I had for you this is
this is your fault you took my part well
you're assuming you would have won you
would have beaten me he told me I was
going to
answer do you think you would have
beaten me
I don't know
I think you'd have been a pretty goofy
competitor isn't it like a voting thing
oh then I definitely want to beat you I
got a feeling that you you might but it
would have been Fair no it wouldn't it
be it wouldn't have been Fair he'd have
had another reason to to vote for you
um you mocked his hair
at one stage and he said if he cut it
he'd lose his power like he was some
sort of Samson right this is great he
asked me something he goes uh
because I want to ask you a question and
and it's it might be it might be rude
you know why so I was gearing up for
some sort of like sex question or you
know what I mean like and it wasn't it
was it was a question about I think it
was how much we get paid
for a scene right um and I was like oh
that's not offensive and I answered his
questions and explained the different
you know pay brackets and men versus
women and sex acts and whatever and he
was like oh
I want to ask you a question it is
offensive
and he goes okay I go
with the hair like you have to doubt and
then he you know he told me that
um
because around the same time he was
doing something on one of the wrestling
things and the bet with Vincent man was
like he lost he got his hair I was like
what would you have done he goes oh no
no
it was never gonna happen he goes it's
kind of my trademark he goes That's the
big thing he's like I always have these
people want to give me a makeover and
and I was like oh so this is this is a a
choice
he's like yeah I guess that's just it's
my it's my it's my trademark and and I
was like oh
like Samson anyway that's how that
conversation so you're having a good
business conversation absolutely you're
getting on well you like him you don't
have any sexual desire but then it all
changes because you go to the room he
also in his defense okay does that just
come out of my mouth in Donald Trump's
defense I said that didn't I you did say
that okay
um he also
wasn't leering or flirting there was no
footsie under the table I mean when I
was talking to him he wasn't staring at
my you know what I mean like it didn't
it didn't feel creepy creepy at all but
then it will change changes and the you
went to the restroom when you come out a
little bit later he's now on the bed and
it's an interesting thing about you've
always said it was all completely
consensual but you told Vogue magazine
in the last few days you give an
interesting version of the event and I
wanted to read it to you and just get
you to clarify absolutely people have
made a lot of assumptions based on what
you said he said I'm standing there on
the door when all of a sudden he's there
in his underwear doing the world's worst
Burt Reynolds impression and that's the
thing I don't understand I don't
understand how I got from the doorway to
being underneath him in the bed I
remember thinking his bodyguard is right
outside that door what happens if I hit
him is that bodyguard going to come in
here and hurt me I remember him saying
do you want to go back to the trailer
park yeah and I never mentioned a
trailer park I didn't grow up in a
trailer park close right but not
and even if you read my book let me just
finish the what you said here I never
said I lived in a trailer park I didn't
I said we were poor I don't remember
taking off my shoes and that's what gets
me because these were gold shoes with
buckles kind of a pain in the ass to put
on takeoff you know and I know I took
them off because I had to put them back
on again and I remember that putting
them on and it being a thing because I
wanted to leave afterwards I know I
didn't say no she adds but I also know I
didn't say yes right I wasn't threatened
I don't know I just don't know yeah even
if you read my book every detail I could
tell you what he had in his toiletry bag
in the bathroom because I dug through it
um like I could tell you the pro but
reading what you told voters and there's
just this missing space right so people
have tried to sort of draw and then I
would like to read it I was not drugged
people like oh it must have been a real
absolute no alcohol no drugs
absolutely not but do you believe it was
all consensual then or not
um it wasn't non-consensual and that
brings us kind of back to where we are
you know in the world now like does it
have to be a clear guess like are men
getting punished for things that
every time you make love to somebody or
go on a date do you have to have written
consent you know what I mean like people
are like oh you need to take
responsibility for going to this Mary
guys hotel room while I've explained the
hotel room part
um and it wasn't to go to his room we
were supposed to go to dinner and then
we didn't
um but I do take responsibility
um I froze I I didn't lead him on it
didn't flirt it wasn't a transaction but
you're not saying he forced himself no
he did he didn't physically come at me I
mean I could have taken him we both know
that I suspect that's true
um but I I did freeze but then you're in
this whole gray area of like
what constitutes consent and non-consent
and I that is honestly to be completely
truthful with you I am still
wrestling with buying for me my husband
had a long conversation the other night
about different scenarios and how the a
blanket
thing doesn't apply you know what I mean
it's just
and I was so terrified back then of
um not being taken serious or and then
people like well why did you go back and
see him multiple times because I didn't
want it to have been for nothing I just
made sure I was never alone with him
again
um so when it when it was over the sex
part
you left quite soon after that oh yeah
within five minutes really four and a
half of which probably me trying to do
those damn little gold buckles and when
you left what were you feeling
uh nauseous like just mad at myself I
was in
I I was just like what what did I
misread you know what I mean and as a
woman especially from the south and back
then like there's this whole thing like
well
what is the word I'm looking for that
somehow it's our fault you know oh you
were asking for it was your skirts you
know that mentality so I just literally
like sat up and was replaying every like
what could I have done or said that was
misconstrued and then when I realized
absolutely nothing I was kind of a [__]
honestly
um
what did I miss from him
nothing like I just you know what I mean
and my flowing was blowing up obviously
the people who knew that I'd gone to
dinner wanted to know like where are you
like what happened like blah blah how
many people knew what had happened that
night no just generally in the next few
weeks months years 100 oh a lot of
people yeah that's the crazy thing like
everybody knew where I was going that
night I was with before I even went to
his room one two three four like seven
people knew where I was going
um afterwards everybody knew he called
weekly I'd put him on speakerphone in
front of my entire crew and it was not
it was not a secret and you met him a
number of times afterwards he went to
his office in New York and then I think
the following month he went to a party
here in La you went to a Miss USA
pageant and each time you met him I did
not meet him in person at the pageant he
just set up at the car service and the
tickets and everything but when you saw
him was it perfectly normal between you
I
you know
in my skin crawl and I was just very
careful not to
be put in that situation again and he
definitely you know
thought that he definitely wanted to
revisit right
um
I mean I can't even be mad at him for I
mean wouldn't you oh we've done this
before
you know I'm not even upset about that
you asked him on that first night about
his wife Milani they didn't be married
quite recently she just given birth to
their son
what did you feel about that you've been
criticized for that part of it you've
already said that yeah also why I didn't
think anything was going to happen
you know what I mean like why would I
assume that this person was going to be
half dressed and
outside a bathroom door when we had
talked about his daughter which people
tried to sexualize and it absolutely
wasn't thank you yeah
um and he had shown me pictures of of
his wife and son
he did
and what did you feel about that oh
we're just talking about cutie was
nothing different than if I I don't know
if you have Victoria if we show pictures
right now of each other's kids like oh
look
at the fit you know you said that it was
only when you had your own child later
that you began to feel a bit differently
about the whole thing because you
realize
the reality perhaps right but it
sharing of photos it was it was what
people do what they mean like I mean
someone tweeted you last week and said
why did you sleep with him even though
you knew he had a wife and you replied
why did he invite me to his room take
over his clothes and Corner me when I
came out of the bathroom even though he
knew he had a wife exactly
like why
why is anyone
responsible for somebody else's behavior
in their marriage I didn't take a vow
and
to you know well as anybody it's
there's this whole thing like where you
blame the other woman but in the other
scenario you rarely blame the other guy
you know what I mean it's just somebody
tweeted you as well last week
I was like I bet I know what you're
gonna ask well they said president Trump
wouldn't touch you with a 10-foot pole
and he replied true he used a three-inch
one one of my finest moments yes
and you're sharp and Sassy on Twitter
and you'll probably exact exactly like
him actually oh in the sense oh I'm
gonna Kanye you right now
here's what I meant on Twitter you take
no prisoners
spell way better than
do you think he was using the
possibility of you appearing on
Celebrity Apprentice which would have
been great for you just like he was
using that as a way to have sex with you
because I would imagine knowing him and
that show I believe if he could have
persuaded you to be on the show and he
could have cleared it with NBC he'd have
done it I absolutely agree with you
100 and a lot of people hate when I say
that yeah
people who people who hate him or
whatever and I'm like
I'm not a fan of me
I believe with all my heart that he was
absolutely serious
um and the reason that I believe that is
because I was sitting across from him
watching his wills turn and I was he was
putting the pieces together I was I was
watching a moment of Genius at work and
he was great at casting and he knew what
would make great TV I suspect what
happened is NBC that's exactly prepared
to take the risk that's exactly what
happened so he got this idea
um and I think it was sort of
in my opinion because I can't remember
the exact word for word was that he felt
sympathy because of the way that Ivanka
had been and treated because you know
she's obviously blonde and beautiful and
then that's when he said you remind me
of your daughter like it wasn't this
creepy pedophile thing that people tried
to spin it the people probably didn't
take her serious and he was like wait I
got an idea
oh this would be great and I was like
that's never gonna happen and he's like
no no no it's going to be great he knew
that it was going to be Sensational he
wanted the Press he loves that he was
definitely he wasn't doing it you'd have
been a brilliant contestant and he
wasn't doing it as a favor for me he was
absolutely I'm actually very glad you
didn't go in there oh yeah you know more
so I would have won all right do I
inseminate you you're just a tough
cookie and I reckon you'd be pretty
smart Apprentice yeah but but he did he
had he had a motive for wanting ah he
wanted the Press he wanted to be known
as the Chris he was absolutely valid but
then I was like it's never going to
happen NBC is not going to go for it and
you meet him at the Beverly Hills Hotel
in July 2007 when they're nearing the
end of the casting thing and you know
you've already met him a few times since
and he stayed in touch by a phone yeah
and it was the same drone over and over
I think to answer your question in a
nutshell he was absolutely serious he
was absolutely genuine he meant it with
all of his heart I was also correct that
they would never let that happen I think
he knew sooner than he let on him and he
dragged it right did he tell you at the
Beverly Hills Hotel that you weren't
going to be no it was later yes on a
phone call
you didn't have sex with him when you
made him at the Beverly Hills Hotel why
not
because I didn't want to but did he want
to of course he did I told him I was on
my period And I had my my then boyfriend
outside
how did he react to that
you know what he was super busy his
phone kept bringing him and
you know then he just wanted to know how
long I was in town and when we could
meet up again I just kept but that was
the last time you spoke to him no the
last time I saw him did you speak to him
again many times for how long after that
I want to say roughly three months for
three months yeah and then it stopped I
stopped answering the phone did you why
because I one I knew that it wasn't
going to happen he he told me The
Apprentice right that it was someone
which I remember the name it got all the
way up this is his what he told me I've
this is hearsay
um that it went all the way up and it
was someone's wife that had an issue and
they and he kind of had to back down as
a favor and the woman had an unusual
name so if you said it I would know it
but I can't think of it off the top of
my head
um and then I just sort of didn't and
then I had you know gotten more serious
with the guys with at the time and then
he had proposed and it was just you know
done and you never spoke to him again
no the irony is on the Celebrity
Apprentice that series
was Tito Ortiz and UFC fight it you know
what I just lied to you accidentally I
stopped answering his calls I didn't
hear from him for a long time I think he
got the message and he did call one
other time and I answered it and he said
I know you're probably going to be mad
at me because Jenna Jameson was just on
the celebrity he was the mother of
Tito's children right he goes it wasn't
I met her yeah when she came on the show
I yeah he did call one other time to
apologize for that yeah because he
thought I was gonna be mad at him and he
wanted me to know that it wasn't his
plan and that he hadn't picked her over
me and it was how did you feel about
that were you annoyed
oh no I I actually believed him in that
one she wasn't contestant it was her
right but but he just he seemed very
concerned of what I would think about
that so three months after that that's
it you have no more contact in May 2011
so this is what six years later you
finally agree to tell your story to In
Touch magazine right for fifteen
thousand dollars it was reported is that
correct yes
why did you want to do it then okay so I
didn't
um I had just had a baby I don't know do
you have children I do okay so your your
wife are now nobody wants to be
photographed or fight or do anything
when that has just happened and you
can't even stand up straight and you
look you know like you just had a baby
and
like I said the story was La everybody
knew hadn't talked about it in years I
am now married to someone who's a little
said like emotional sense that we just
had a baby whatever and I got the call
that someone had basically sold the
story and Linkedin they're sniffing
around I have no evidence of who that is
I have a I'm 90 sure I know who it was I
just can't prove us have to be very
careful what I say
um and I was like nope nope nope
absolutely not not interested and then
you know finally he comes back and
they're like well he's gonna you know
this person's gonna tell the story and
get paid unless you want to do it
instead
it's going to come out anyway would you
rather it be your version and you get
the money or this other person's version
and you get nothing and they've made
money off of you so you decided to do it
so I decided to do it and they asked if
I would take a lie detector test I was
gonna say you took a polygraph and I
said absolutely and I passed and
actually it was corroborated the story
by one of your good friends and
supported by your ex-husband both of
whom also passed right polygraph tests
so you've got three people who were
aware of the account you gave all of
whom passed polygraph tests that's
pretty compelling uh evidence but the
story never ran and two former employees
of In Touch magazine lady said it didn't
run because after they called Donald
Trump seeking comment right his attorney
Michael Cohen threatened to sue them
are you sure it was Michael Cohen I
didn't know that was his attorney back
then I just knew there was his attorney
I I can't validate if it was actually
Cohen but it was a lawyer a lawyer yeah
I'm not sure if it was Cohen and um I
was like oh you know thank God because I
didn't want to come out anyway because I
mean look at like you know no right
um so it went away I thought it went
away and then you were almost relieved
even oh absolutely even though you've
taken that decision to talk about it
right part of you was still like I don't
know well the only reason I took the
decision to talk about it was I was
taking back control because it was going
to be talked about anyway
just like I'm sitting here talking to
you instead of having you talk to a
friend of a friend you understand that
but you never got paid then no because
it never came out and a few weeks later
you were in a car park in Vegas right
and a man comes up to you
and he threatens you very directly says
leave Trump alone forget the story
that's a beautiful little girl pointing
to your daughter it'd be a shame if
something happened to her mum yes I mean
horrendous thing to happen yeah and you
know what's funny is I did the gravity
of it didn't even hit me until I was
already
in the elevator
I mean it's Vegas it's hot I'm running
late for a mommy and me class and I
remember how tiny she was because she
was still facing backwards and the guy
was
super good looking actually like I
didn't have any hesitation about him
walking up
to my car it was a nice area women
coming and going and I just thought it
was somebody's boyfriend or husband and
I even like I was like oh he's cute and
I remember it so clearly because he was
wearing my favorite jeans
so it's like just the weirdest things
stuck out of my head so then you know
you get out you gather all your things
and trying to get the car seat unclipped
and that's when he walked up and he just
was so nice looking and honestly
handsome that it didn't even a chilling
thing to say right and I was just like
oh
did that just happen is that why you
didn't report to the police that you
were worried about any repercussions
absolutely yeah and because at that
point it had gone away and that's what I
really wanted anyway
so nothing appears no and then in June
2015 Donald Trump announces he's running
for president
what is your reaction to that
eye roll
eye roller also a slight trepidation
nope not at all you didn't worry about
what had happened no because he had
straight up told me he never wanted to
be president
like he straight up told me that really
yes and he's like wow he's like
something you know some people want me
to become president and I was like he's
like why would I ever do that this is
way more like all the reasons I don't
want to be president like why would I it
sounds like a terrible freaking job you
know what I mean and he was like this is
what I I don't need the money I have
this
all valid
points you just rolled your eyes you
just thought yeah I was just like do you
ever think he could win
I didn't even think he was actually
I thought it was another one of his but
stormy on The Apprentice or go on WWE
yeah of course why not
but he then wins the nomination and he
looks like he's heading to to
potentially win against Hillary Clinton
then on October 7th 2016 just before the
election this tape from Access Hollywood
behind the scenes tape and dropped
and it was Infamous it included him
saying you can just do what you like
when you're famous a woman you can grab
them by the [__]
you said recently this [__] grabbed
back talking about yourself but when you
when you heard that tape what did you
think did you think as some people did
that he was genuinely meaning every word
of that that he was a sexual predator
who would do that to women or do you
think as he put it this was locker room
banter and that he meant really if
you're famous women gravitate around you
yes all of the above it could have been
either and probably a little bit of all
the above yeah
I mean
obviously he's gotten away with it so
what he was saying is partially truthful
do you think he got away with that with
you
yeah
but not anymore
you then go after this story breaks you
and your attorney Keith Davidson go to
the National Enquirer did you go to them
or did they come to you I don't know I
wasn't part of it
I never spoke to them
um but they say you're willing to go on
the record about having the effect this
is three weeks before the election right
keep in mind I have
all these people in my life hitting me
up
remembering because they had heard him
after the Access Hollywood tape drops
right hitting me up that you know knew
from back then a lot of people that I
work with are the same people that I'd
worked with before and they remember it
and and so now they're like you got to
do something or you got to come far
we're gonna you know even people at my
own company were pushing me to come
forward and make some sort of crusade
out of it and you know here's your
chance I was like this is not I don't
want any part of this you know what I
mean but the same thing it wasn't a
secret
so it wasn't like oh suddenly I've got
this opportunity to you know
I don't even think anybody would be
interested and I'm a porn star you know
what I mean so I
I have I was not part of who call who
whatever but I do know that everyone was
calling me I do know that friends were
were you know telling me they were gonna
talk about what you know what they knew
so you thought again I can get in and
tell my story the way I want to tell it
I don't remember if the word Inquirer
was straight mentioned to me I could be
wrong it was just a lot has happened
because the stories of The Inquirer CEO
in others have then contacted Michael
Cohen who then offered you 130 000 for
the story rights and for you to sign an
NDA a legally enforceable document
written to ensure the story won't
actually ever be made publicly so I kind
of catch and kill they call it right
where the inquiries Corporation because
they had good relationship with Donald
Trump and thought he might become
president right
so you agreed to this and you signed the
NDA and you accept this deal the
document didn't include Trump's
signature it had a space for it but he
hadn't signed it it was a separate
letter so why did you do the deal
uh so
two parts of that I wanted it to go away
I was told it was to not release the
story
there was catch and kill I didn't even
know that part I was told it wasn't
going to come out
um which is exactly what I wanted I
didn't want this coming out I had this
great life I was living in Texas
everything was great it was the [__]
last thing I wanted
um and then I had what you don't know
and I have talked about it's in my book
but people just
um is that they're before that
um I have a friend that's an attorney
not my attorney
um that I was friends with
in Texas it was talking about how oh you
know he knew the story from way back
when I know you should say something
blah blah I was like he doesn't even
want to be president I was like I'm sure
he's not even he's it's some sort of
he's either In Cahoots so Hillary
remember he backed her before which
makes sense or there's something going
on here I'm not worried about it and he
was like all right all right and then he
got the nomination and then he his whole
tone with me changed and he was like I'm
concerned I was like why he goes well
now as big of a doofus as he is now he's
still actually the Republican party's
problem
and they're going to have to clean up
his mass and get rid of skeletons I
wouldn't be surprised if you died in a
single car accident or you OD'd I was
like what he's you're their problem now
like think about it think about what
happened to like all these people I was
like but then I was like I went down a
rabbit hole in Google will happen to
Marilyn Monroe I think he named a bunch
of other and I was like oh my gosh and
then they approached me with the NDA
and I was like what do you think I
should do and he goes well I think you
should come forward and stop him from he
goes but as your friends
at least if you sign this and there's
payment there's a paper trial and they
can't hurt you
and I was like that made sense it makes
absolute sense and he was like
he goes why you though he's like you
can't be the only woman I was like yeah
maybe because I'm the most famous and I
was like no actually I don't think it's
about the sex at all I honestly think
coming forward back then people have
been like bringing another hot like it
wouldn't have hurt him
you know what I mean it wouldn't have
done any damage to him and just me
I think it was they were afraid of the
other knowledge I don't think it had
anything to do with any of the sex acts
that the the media or public is so
fixated on because of you know sex is
salacious and it's exciting but I think
it has to do more with the Celebrity
Apprentice thing that he was literally
gonna rig
you know a television show or that I
heard him on the phone with Hillary or
that I heard him like there's all these
other things that I thought
they were more concerned about because
you know they went to him and was like
okay all right
does she know anything else
and I think that's why I was the one
that was approached I have no proof that
is my opinion interesting
so he becomes president what are you
feeling that this guy that you had sex
with is another president of the United
States
I don't even know
America just became a reality show see
how this goes you know does he know
anything about being like
did you try and contact him or not no of
course not throw out any of his prices
oh absolutely not
absolutely not in January 2018 so this
is the year after his inauguration The
Wall Street Journal reports on the deal
and Michael Cohen States publicly he
paid you using his own money he wasn't
directed to by Donald Trump
and you respond by suing Trump and Cohen
seeking to have the NDA invalidated
right but because he didn't sign him and
because he said he wouldn't enforce it
the case was dismissed and then things
start to spiral
And to clarify
because this is where people mess up all
the time the case dismissed in my favor
which means I was released from the NDA
right
if you wanted to right it was no longer
valid I was released because he hadn't
signed anything he hadn't signed it and
also they had broken it they had broken
the the stipulations in the NDA not once
not twice but three times before I ever
did
so you then issue a letter and this has
been very contentious oh here we go yes
this is one of those things I'm telling
you that people don't write so this is
in the same month that story gets
reported by also Johnny you say to whom
it may concern over the past few weeks
I've been asked countless times to
comment on reports of an alleged sexual
relationship I have a Donald Trump many
many many years ago the fact of the
matter is that each party to this
alleged Affair denied its existence in
2006-2011 2016 2017 and now again in
2018 I'm not denying this affair because
I was paid hush money as it's been
reported and overseas owned tabloids I'm
denying this affair because it never
happened I'll have no further comment on
this matter please feel free to check me
out on Instagram Stormy Daniels so
that's the second one right so explain
to me though that's the second one there
was one before that right so people
point to the contents of this letter and
they say well what changed I mean you
couldn't have been more categoric in
saying I was still under the NDA and
Michael Cohen wrote that and had me sign
it and I didn't want to which is why I
signed my name wrong right before I went
on Kimmel and pointed it out how did you
sign your name
it doesn't it doesn't look like my
signature oh I see yeah but you were
still under the NDA so you felt obliged
to do this I was told if I didn't and
they'd see me for the 20 million or
whatever it was
I had not been released from the NDA
people say and you know this because
it's been blazing around on Twitter in
the last week this is some new well no
there's only people say that it's new
well they say well this is the letter
the cruise they say this is not an
approved Stormy Daniels can't be trusted
or believed what do you say to those
people I said I'm the only one that can
be because I was the last one upholding
the original agreement I was the last
one doing what I was supposed to do
um also that's I never testified in
court that wasn't done under oath that
was printed off of an email that Cohen
said to somebody to send to somebody uh
it's not notarized it's not endorsed
it's not an affidavit it's not perjury
and I didn't break the NDA
because if I hadn't signed that I would
have broken the NDA
if you would if you had not denied it if
I had not done what they told me to do
if I'd come forward and
you know said the truth then I would
have been liable and I wouldn't have
been able to be released several months
later your then lawyer Michael avenatti
released a sketch of the guy we're not
going to get into him
released a sketch of the guy who
threatened you in Vegas and Donald Trump
tweeted a sketch years later about a
non-existent man a total con job playing
the fake news media for fools but they
know it
and in May the next month he tweeted
that he paid the money via Michael Cohen
because the agreement was used to stop
the false and extortionist accusations
made about her you about an affair
you then sued for defamation right
against Trump because he was accusing
you of inventing the Vegas incident with
this guy who threatened you even though
there were Witnesses and you know what I
mean like
that was this is this is the this is the
Crux of the whole thing for me is that
going back to that I assumed to get
released from the NDA it was dismissed
in my favor
Trump owes my attorney attorney's fees I
won that so I did not break the NDA
um if anything I was the last one
standing holding it up
um then the defamation suit
Michael avenatti wanted to file that I
told him absolutely not no no no no
he goes why I go
I get called way worse things by the
minute
I don't this is not working once you go
down the defamation Bridge actually very
hard in America to prove destination
right and so I was anti I actually found
out on Twitter that Michael avenatti had
filed that lawsuit that's how you've
discovered uh-huh I was on my tour bus
and to be clear he then went to prison
because he was up to all sorts of stuff
right and not anything to do with that
particular case
um but
no no no no he didn't say anything that
bad and then somebody pointed out
because that's when the narrative got
well the first time it got really nasty
towards me is I was like oh my gosh it
it is defamation I could be like I think
you're stupid
I think you're ugly that's my opinion I
can say whatever I want if I say peers
you're a rapist or you're a thief
that is defamation and he called me a
liar
and that is defamation so I was like oh
I guess everybody's kind of right but
then he messed up the paperwork and
missed a deadline and they didn't have
any precedent for going after setting
president so I lost the defamation scene
so ultimately yeah you lost it and they
explained it because of Trump's First
Amendment right to free speech that was
upheld on appeal and Supreme Court
decline to review so that was the legal
process
not free speech to call somebody
something untrue that's not an opinion
it is defamation and I believe if he
hadn't been who he was and most
importantly I wasn't who I am that the
outcome of that case would be default
because you were a pawn star and he was
President of the United States you
didn't have a chance of winning it was
unfair absolutely the justice system
failed me on that and is that another
reason why you felt ecstatic when you
heard you've been indicted absolutely
on the 16th this has been repeated
repeatedly proven that of all things I
might be a [__] but I'm an honest [__]
like I'm the only one that has told the
truth the whole time Cohen went to
prison for it like we have
I'm gonna come to that uh on the 16th of
October 2018 so towards the end of that
year Trump tweeted a federal judge
throws out Stormy Daniels lawsuit versus
Trump Trump's entitled to full legal
fees great he says now I can go after
horse face and her third-rate lawyer in
the great state of Texas please tell me
you're going to read one of my favorites
she will confirm a letter she's signed
she knows nothing about it a total calm
how did you feel about being called
horse face by the president United
States
I
laugh say a lot of things by the way
look I don't actually look like a horse
anything I did
exactly they're beautiful but
my response just sums up exactly like
like how do you
what did you say
how it's so brilliant it's basically
like our president of the United States
ladies and gentlemen outing to the world
he has a penchant for bestiality because
this is a guy who chased me for sex
repeatedly and then says I look like a
horse face like
how do you talk about the looks of
someone that you were attracted to
without making yourself look bad I mean
it was hilarious
you said that you spent some of the 130
000 on a horse trailer trust me I
appreciate the hilarious irony of that
too that's right up there with the whole
what else did you spend it on I think I
just pay it we just paid off Home
Improvement stuff like that but you
wrote stuff but in the defamation case
because you lost you were ordered to pay
half a million dollars in legal cost to
Trump attorneys that was split over the
original case in the appeal and you've
just been ordered yesterday my court
here in California to pay another
hundred and twenty thousand dollars in
legal fees again over all that the
defamation case that's over 600 000 now
how much have you paid so far
um zero and some of that is offset I
don't know the exact numbers you'd have
to check is all available he I've won
against him several times too so it's
that's not the accurate number because
the attorney series I have won
take do you know in that case how much
no I have no idea you said I will go to
jail before I pay a penny absolutely
because the justice system failed me so
you're not going to pay it no even if it
means that you're held in contempt and
go to jail yep you're prepared to do
that yes
I didn't come this far to back down and
to give him money
I will say
that his attorneys however
are owed the money that you know what I
mean like they did a job
but your argument is he was calling you
a liar Yes actually he was the liar yes
so why should you be paying money for a
case which in the end found for someone
that you believe was the one telling the
lies you said it better than I did
well that's your position yes and I
think that it's accurate it's been
proven over and over that I wasn't lying
like Michael like I said Michael Cohen
went to prison and they're still like
that's like giving you know not the same
degree I'm not downplaying like a more
serious crime you know but that's like
having to pay your rapist for the sex
like what like I did nothing wrong but
stand up to him and prove that I wasn't
lying I'm not that's not fair
and I did have a legal defense fund but
Michael avenatti stole that too right
in May 2019 Cohen didn't go to prison uh
another woman that was then established
would have had a relationship with him
former Playboy model Carol McDougall
such as a 10-month relationship with
Trump from 2006 to seven did you know
Karen have you have you met Karen do you
know her
um funny story no I didn't even know she
existed
um I don't even know if I really knew
her name maybe I knew there was a play
name Cara whatever
she
Trump's a man he's a player man he had
me and Karen at the same vodka party and
introduced us and we shook hands what
yeah
the Trump vodka party in Hollywood I
went there with my friend Tara Patrick
and her husband just introduced you yeah
I shook hands with carroman doodle we
had at the time you now know he was
having a relationship with her too
I mean that takes a brown snack exactly
what do you feel about that
honestly
impressed
have you spoken to her since
no I mean I was just hi nice to meet you
it wasn't you had no contact no
but you you weren't surprised that she
got 150 000 payoff because did you think
that's just what Trump did maybe I I you
know I can't I I don't remember
I mean it's not like I had a strong
either way I was probably like when I I
think it was more like oh I wonder who's
next I expected there to be like a long
line
how is your life now
I mean
um interesting always an adventure are
you happy it's never boring it's not
boring it's never boring it's one of a
better phrase It's been stormy there you
go but are you are you a happy person I
so overall I mean stuff get I mean I'm a
normal person
you know what I mean like I I write and
direct movies I love doing that I'm
trying really hard to to get I was
almost sort of over this and wanted to
go back to being taken seriously as a a
writer and director and directing a
horror movie but
here comes the orange hobgoblin again to
mess everything up
um
you know I
I have my horse and and you know my kids
doing great especially compete I used to
yeah I haven't in five years since it
started
um and what's it like being a mother
through all this
um that's the one thing that was taken
for me that can never be given back was
time lost with with my daughter and I
get really upset about it that's what
affects me the most and I'll get
emotional and cry and then you know why
because she didn't ask for this you know
what I mean and there's things that I
missed because for a long period of time
the only way to keep her safe was to be
advertised to being somewhere else press
isn't going to show up and knock on the
door and chase her home you know if they
know I'm on stage in another city so I
stayed away a lot to protect her and it
worked
uh but at the same time
maybe somehow I've created a world
that's a little bit safer for her to
feel like
she could speak her voice one day if she
ever needs to what does she think of
what you've done she thinks I'm a hero
how does that make you feel
it might be
when my book first came out she was
small and obviously not privy to any of
the information inside but she was with
me
at a horse show and
my publicists arrive at the first
physical copy how did you get that and
he walked up and he gave it to me the
friend of my book it's dedicated to her
and she was sitting there and I walked
over I was like I showed it I was like
you can't read this for at least 10
years but read the first page
and she opened it and started crying and
yeah what's the first page it says it's
you know it's dedicated to my beautiful
daughter and she and she was very
emotional about that and then
um I said I'm I'm sorry that I don't get
to see you and she goes that's okay
Mommy I understand that there's other
little girls out there that need your
help more than I do right now wow from
like a seven-year-old and I was like
that's quite something Jackie Coke
double pleased
how's she doing though she's fantastic
she's fantastic straight A student
artist really how old is she now she's
12. straight straight she's beautiful
and smart and I would like to take full
credit for that but she's very much a
Mixter of me and her wonderful dad
you married for the fourth time uh to
someone who'd also been in the adult
entertainment business Barrett blade was
his his name in the movies full-time
lucky let's hope so he's here
watching
it's a real genuine love story because
when you were 19 or you'd ever gone into
the adult business you met at a concert
he was touring with a band and you meet
right and then a few years later I was
mean to him you were I was really mean
to have because my friend dragged me to
this show and then wanted to borrow my
car to go hook up with a guy so she left
me alone
sitting there and he walked up and like
I thought he was hitting me or tried to
buy me a drink and I was underage and I
was so snarky I was like I have x's on
my hand and then I was stranded there so
I ended up forced to talk to him for
like four hours and I ended up actually
really hitting off and we became you
know we didn't become friends because
that was before social media and I you
know I didn't have a cell I lost track
of him we lost track and then four years
later we bumped into each other on an
adult side well that's an amazing thing
and then he didn't remember my name
I said Barrett and he was like Baton
Rouge which made me like this
[__] got a chicken every city
but you actually met again on the set of
an adult movie where you he's your male
coaster right
he was your first male coaster is that
right yeah like yeah that was your debut
I had done a bunch of scenes before that
but they were with girls and so we
worked together and then there's this
guy that you met yeah I was like oh my
gosh this is amazing because I was like
had such a crush on him that night he'd
actually wanted to have sex with her
yeah and he didn't even kiss me and now
how massive now I do get to have sex
with videos my name
see I make poor choices
there's a pattern here there is a
pattern yeah
um and then he went on to we worked
together quite a bit and then he moved
to behind the camera he's a very
talented Director of Photography and and
cinematographer so he shot a lot of my
movies when I was a director but we
never date it
and then eventually he just decides he's
got to tell you he loves you I think he
got drunk and texts me because he just
randomly texted me I think we should get
married and I thought he was joking and
then I think we just didn't want to
admit we were kidding and now we're
married done
but I mean it kind of did happen a lot
yeah and I was like dude he's no way
he's serious and then I met his family
oh no no he's been saying you're he was
going to marry you for like 10 years I'm
like why didn't you tell me so this
whole time he felt this way about you
yeah and you probably quietly felt that
about him absolutely so when we started
dating we got together we're like oh my
God everybody's gonna be so shy it's
gonna be the gossip in the porn World
everybody's like yeah about time like no
one
no I was like yeah we do
oh then you're a shitty friend because
you didn't tell us
like like nobody was surprised we
thought oh everybody's gonna be so
Shockwave do we do our first event
together and everybody's like oh my God
everybody's like checked out you got
married on the 24th anniversary to the
day from the day you first met that
concert
was that deliberate yes
and when you got married that day what
did you feel about this extraordinary
Arc of this relationship with this guy
ah like finally something came full
circle and felt right and it really does
it just feels right like it just I feel
like true love oh for sure and uh but
for the first time true love for you
it's a no like I
I've definitely been in love with other
people but this is like it's deeper it's
you know he's my he's my friend my
co-worker my family like we've been
through so much and he knows who I
really am and it's just
yes it's exciting and passionate yeah
two porn stars going at it like what do
you expect like obviously it's the sex
is amazing as I think you must be his
mom's over there over there
so like it is the sex as good as we all
assume it must it's better
but that's to be good it's it's the
other stuff that is the great thing it's
just um
it's easy
he understands you yeah and what he
doesn't understand he accepts and vice
versa what does he feel about Trump and
what's been going on I'm not going to
speak for him
if they were in a bar together
would it very quickly descend into
the way the
South tend to resolve these things
that's a very diplomatic way of putting
it
bless his heart you
um you were before when your parents
split up yes and you've talked very
openly about being raised by a mother
who's pretty neglectful
um you better be crazy did you what
happened to your relationship with your
parents
um what's
is he still alive or not yes do you see
him no what about your mother and he
paid he did all the things he was
legally obligated to do
um
get a mess up way I don't have anything
bad to say about him you know what I
mean uh my mom I
I mean it was just kind of Rocky all the
way through
um she's a whole different
situation uh we go on and off and on
again you speak to her or not no
absolutely not I have not talked to her
since the day my daughter was born why
because when I looked at my daughter I
realized that
she deserved better than I have somebody
like that in her life
does that make sense like did your
parents ever ever tell you they loved
you
I mean I don't know if they meant it but
yeah well yeah they didn't but you felt
you wanted to give your daughter the
kind of parenting that you'd never had
right I mean my mother was neglectful
and then I mean
I cried just to give you start to
clickbait uh perfect scenario my mother
that I hadn't talked to in 10 years I
find online in some British public like
daily something uh that she'd done a
story and sold a bunch of baby pictures
of me and half of the baby pictures
weren't even me
really yeah so begs the question is she
so crazy that she really thought those
were pictures of me or is she so evil
that she sold baby pictures of somebody
else I don't know you're the journalist
figured out that's not good either way
is it no
um I heard that you originally wanted to
be a journalist I know what was that
thinking I think you'd be pretty good
actually
um I did because in my high school that
was the only course for kind of writing
never wondered because you went into
strip clubs you know age 17 and we're an
instant huge hit people loved you were
so many stuff but do you ever wonder
again the parallel line if you'd become
a journalist I'd actually abandon the
journalism thing before that because I
wrote for the high school paper and
there's not a lot of creativity like
it's you know and I'm a much better
Storyteller with a bigger platform like
you know to write novels or
scripts I mean like how many scripts all
right that's that's my passion is to be
able to tell the story like that Stormy
Daniels is your stage name for one of a
better phrase
um Stephanie Clifford is actually one of
your married names right you originally
were Stephanie Gregory which one
do you like to be Stormy Daniels
because I created her myself
how much like Stormy Daniels is the real
you oh
I would say as close to 100
that's pretty much the same yeah
what is the biggest misconception about
Stormy Daniels
um that I'm a liar
uh that
I you know I have nothing no other
talents but
you know laying on my back which by the
way I do a lot of work kneeling and
standing as well thank you very much
[Laughter]
um you know but I am a writer and
director and sustain of communion and
and as a person what do you think your
strongest assets are in terms of values
what what do you think you stand for
um
being truthful like almost to a fault
giving too many giving people too many
chances like trying to find the good in
people and I have a hard time saying no
when someone needs something you know I
will answer the phone at three o'clock
in the morning I may not be the one to
help you change your tire but I'll make
sure that somebody gets I will pay
somebody to do it for you
um and you're tough clearly and you've
got guts yeah nobody would go through
what you've gone through yeah without
having a backbone
yeah but I'm also a Pisces so I'll punch
you in the face but I will cry my eyes
out about it later
in your interview with in touch all
those years ago 12 years ago
they asked if you had a message for
Donald Trump and you said karma will
always bite you in the ass
that staged pretty well that maybe I'll
name my next horse Karma
you feel a bit of calmer about all this
yeah I mean
I mean
who wouldn't
what are your feelings about him as you
sit here Donald Trump
like in what way like I don't I don't
hate him
you know what I mean like I I actually
it was funny you mentioned I sat with
that maybe yesterday the day before and
you would assume I I would and and I
probably used to and I used to probably
hate a lot of people like just being you
know right or whatever
but I don't really hate do you feel
sorry for him in a way
I don't really hate anyone and and yeah
in a way I I do feel sorry for for him
um
it wouldn't surprise me if if it would
come out that he's been manipulated a
lot more than we than we think or that
based on the things that have happened
to me in the last five years things I
thought would never be possible
um
there could be something that we don't
know
if he's watching this interview and he
probably is knowing him of course he is
what would you say to him
I don't know I'm so torn between
snarky and you know
um
don't get Lube in your eyes it'd be part
of it but like also still like just
tell the truth you know what I mean like
you do have a daughter you do
potentially have granddaughters and and
women you know and if you continue
to do this you were setting a precedent
where people think that they are
it won't be held accountable and there
will be I just I'm afraid there's going
to be a lot of people hurt
do you believe that this goes to trial
this particular case that you will be
completely Vindicated and that it will
be established you've told the truth and
he's lied
that's wishful thinking it will
definitely be a giant step closer in
that direction
but I don't think it'll ever be 100
because there are some people that are
just
so steadfast to their beliefs are so
unwilling to admit that they were wrong
or that he lies or that
you know they just they just can't let
it go they'll always be those
in your senior yearbook there was a
picture of you and the quote next to it
from you you show that picture I will
find you and I swear hahaha
we're definitely using it now I know
where you live now I think that's true
you do
um but you said we all get along
we'll all get along let me do it again
in your senior yearbook you wrote we'll
all get along as soon as you realize
that I am queen
what do you think they'd all be thinking
now your fellow
schoolmates sure listen to her
do you feel in a way you're you're a
queen of something that you're a queen
of bad decisions well maybe that but
also maybe standing up for yeah that one
I'll take I will absolutely proud myself
I will do
the right thing
at the most
bad costs
is that a flaw or a no I think that's a
strength
I think that shows a lot of strength of
character
it's not easy as you've discovered right
right stormy thank you very much thank
you yeah it's been great to meet you
nice to meet you
thank you you're a lot nicer than I was
told
[Laughter]